school bus safety it's something a lot
of kids haven't had to worry about with
months of distance learning but with so
many recent pedestrian deaths on valley
roads the clark county school district
wants to make sure kids know the abcs of
safety kate houston is at rex bell
elementary to explain
yes well as schools focus on health and
safety inside of the classroom this year
they are also making sure kids are safe
on the roadways whether they're taking
the bus or walking to school the theme
this year is be safe know the danger
zone that refers to the blind spot
around the school bus highlighted in red
here ccsd transportation executive
director jennifer vobus says the tires
can generate enough wind to suck in a
pedestrian and it has led to deaths in
commercial buses
as pedestrian hit and runs rise bobis
says this education is just as important
for drivers it's really important for
people to remember that school is back
in session and not only do students ride
the bus but they also walk to school
to slow down especially in the school
zones or if they see students on major
roads that are walking on the sidewalk
ccsd transportation continues to deal
with ongoing staff shortages bobis says
there are currently 240 bus driver
vacancies and they're actively hiring
ccsd rolled out the ride on initiative
with rtc a few weeks ago to help manage
resources vobus says over a thousand
students are participating and 400
others have requested bus passes
reporting near sahara and rancho kate
houston live local now